everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're going to be
continued our coverage of the 2014 chess
rapid world championships if you're not
too familiar with the format's kind of
covering again they play three days of
rapid chess that is 15 minutes per game
or permanent per game and you also get
10 seconds per increment for each move
that you make so you can't get more than
15 minutes in the particular game of a
very very quick chest they play five
matches a day for three straight days to
crown a champion to a lot of chests from
these players they're getting to play a
lot of different players that they
usually don't get to play and even if
you're the number one player in the
world which we're gonna be going over
one of his games right now that doesn't
necessarily mean that you are the best
rapid or blitz player and there's a lot
of players that they can lay some traps
you can fall into some very easy
mistakes that you just don't think about
in the heat of the moment so I thought
it'd be good to go over a game from
around 3:00 from Magnus cross in the top
player in the world right now just won
the world championships against Vladimir
Potkin a Russian Grandmaster very very
good chess player in his own right so
Magnus Carlsen is gonna be playing with
the white pieces and we have Vladimir
Potkin gonna be playing as the black
pieces Magnus Carlsen decides to start
the game out with pawn to e4 makes me
all warm and fuzzy when I see that very
aggressive opening line for Magnus
Carlsen I really enjoyed watching Magnus
Carlsen when he is playing very
aggressive pawn to c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 very common moves
from both side after the exchange we do
see the tamanna variation the pawn here
to e6 and then Knight here to c6 Knight
to c3 Queen c7 normal moves in the
tamanna variation pawn to a6 very
interesting I grew up studying this line
and it was always bishop here to e2
castling on the kingside Magnus Carlsen
goes for a different approach and he
actually plays pawn here to a3 somewhat
of a waiting move does stop his opponent
from playing Knight here to b4 which is
fine so continues with Knight f6 pawn
here to f4 so you can already see Magnus
Carlsen has a very different align that
he's thinking about more of an
aggressive on the Kings side maybe
castle on the Queen side he still could
cast on the King
sign have a you know ruk behind here on
f1 supporting this pawn pushing forward
but it does look like you know his
opponent is gonna be somewhat forced to
castle on the kingside he can kind of go
all-in on the kingside focus on castling
on the Queen side so this he's kind of
taking the variation that that I'm
familiar with and kind of flipped it on
his head and kind of made it more of an
aggressive line which is something you
may want to try to do especially if it's
a rapid game where your opponent may not
be super familiar with it those are the
types of small little incremental
advantages that you can gain because
Magnus Carlsen is familiar with pretty
much every opening a variation much more
so than I would imagine of Vladimir
Potkin we now see the knight exchange so
Queen here to d4 could have taken with
other pieces but this does give him an
aggressive Queen and allows him to
castle on the Queen side that much
faster Knight here to a g4 interesting
variation from here magnus carlsen plays
Queen here to b6 bishop here to d6
pushing forward with a 5
I do like pushing forward with your
central pawns so anytime you can get
your pawns ePHI VAT d5 or even pushing a
little bit further it really starts to
choke your opponent black really hasn't
made much movement with his pawns past
this 6th rank so eventually you can
start to choke his opponent and really
wear down on all the different options
this is a very good move to kind of push
the spatial advantage that Magnus
Carlsen has we do see the knight take
and then the Queen come back here
interesting to note that Magnus Carlsen
did give his opponent the double bishop
pair although it is very difficult
somewhat for for black to utilize that
he doesn't have his LightSquared bishop
even remotely into the game he does need
to get some king sized safety the bishop
is gonna come back here to e7 it was
being attacked we see the castling on
the the Queen side so again from both
sides black really wants to castle on
the King side he wants to give his life
square bishop involved into the action
because it's not doing a whole heck of a
lot he wants to bring his rook over here
to c8 semi-open file you always want
your rooks very very active the more
squares that they can move the buddy are
they are going to be from White's
perspective he knows that blacks going
to castle on the Kings side so he wants
to
just push everything in the kitchen sink
at this kingside start pushing his pawns
start bringing his rook over he doesn't
really matter start throwing his queen
over here a centralized this knight
bring it over to the King side it's not
doing too much on c3 right here so those
are that's kind of what both sides are
gonna be looking to do in this chess
game now that's always interesting when
you do chess commentary sometimes the
opponents don't do and you kind of have
to try to figure out what they're doing
or sometimes is just a huge blunder and
it's very obvious sometimes they do
exactly what you feel like they should
do sometimes that makes you feel smart
but you know it is what it is so in this
particular case we see black play pawn
here to b5 pushing forward on the Queen
side recognized the his opponents
already committed to the Queen side with
his queenside castle does also open up
the door for his bishop to come here to
b7 does need to get that involved into
the action again bishop pair doesn't do
too much if you don't have both bishops
to actually involved into the game night
here to e4 swinging it over to the King
side again on the Queen side is kind of
just sitting there is a defense mode and
Magnus Carlsen the way he's played so
far he's not looking to play defense
mode because if you're playing Vladimir
Potkin Russian Grandmaster that's pretty
good at chess but Magnus Carlsen the
number one chess player in the world he
needs to come out of this with a win
he's not playing for a draw and he's
definitely not playing for a second
place flex going to castle on the Kings
side Bishop here a to d3 bishop here to
b7 Knight here to f6 pretty interesting
doesn't really matter how black attacks
this he could attack with his bishop he
could attack with his pawn and that
would actually be okay for Magnus
Carlsen the compensation that he would
get by opening up this G file you know
in this particular game he feels like it
would be worth it
Vladimir decides to go and take with his
bishop the pawn recaptures an
interesting move in the particular game
he plays pawn to g6 and this is
interesting because this pawn on G on f6
is very very dangerous it has some
really dangerous outpost the Queen can
come up here to h6 and then a quick
checkmate here he could have easily
taken with his pawn here on f6 it's not
quite clear
how magnus carlsen could actually
continue to attack this queen here to g3
king over here to h8 he could always now
bring his rooks over here to kind of
counter-attack on the kingside no longer
is it a strong attack for whites but now
of a counter-attack for black so you
know he could have easily taken this
pawn to material and not had to worry
about these outposts but instead he
plays pawn here to g6 definitely a
questionable move in the particular game
pawn to f5 kind of breaking this up
there's no reason to have doubled pawns
go ahead and attack your opponent maybe
you can have another weakness come up on
the board the Queen coming back here to
d8 someone interesting Queen to g5 I
feel like this kind of a mistake by
Magnus Carlsen you could have easily
played rook over here to f1 this makes a
lot of sense it doesn't really matter
you know let's say we have Queen take
here on f6 and then this pawn takes here
on g6 potentially we have Queen coming
back here to g7 take and then the King
over here again this pawns being
protected by this Bishop here on d3 this
is gonna be very good for Magnus Carlsen
and you know instead he decides to play
a little bit different place Queen here
to g5 pretty aggressive although I think
he could have found something better if
he had a little bit more time rook over
here to c8 yes I do like this move
because it's a semi-open square you need
to get this rook involved but you only
want to play this if it's safe to play
and I don't think he realizes that the
number one play in the world is
completely breathing down his neck on
the King side and he really needs to
focus over there because he's in a lot
of hurt so Magnus Carlsen is just gonna
start gobbling up material pawn takes
there on g6 the pawn recaptures and then
Bishop here to g6 all of a sudden he
it's getting pretty uncomfortable for
black right now as far as what he's
gonna do
i plays Queen here to f6 I don't really
like that move I'm not really sure where
else he's supposed to go I guess he
could take with his pawn here on g6 and
then pawn too you know or the Queen
takes there on g6 it's still kind of
messy not to be confused with the
Argentinian soccer player that scored
earlier today but from here we see the
Queen take on f6 and then a bishop take
on fh7 the King come over here to h8 and
then Queen to h5 putting a lot of
pressure there is a discovered attack
once this Bishop moves we have King here
to a g7 rook up here to d7 a double
attack here attacking both the king and
the bishop right here there's not again
why it has just too many attackers in
this particular game he now plays rook
here to f7 but now Bishop coming back
here it's gonna be a mistake to go ahead
and take with his you know rook because
after you know Queen come back here to
f4 right away
forcing the King to move but then we
actually see the rook take but again
that just loses the Queen here to h7 and
then the roofs gonna fall and all of a
sudden if you kind of look at the board
White's attacking the bishop here on b7
it's attacking the rook there's no way
to kind of defend both of those on board
he can also play rook here to f1 if
blacks not careful he can't defend
everything White's already up white
material on board with two pawns he has
to pass pawns over here so in this
particular case black just decided to go
ahead and resign great game by Magnus
Carlsen and really applying a lot of
pressure to his opponent one little
small error by his opponents and all of
a sudden Magnus Carlsen went on to
dominate the game so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this always fun to watch rapid
chess because they're playing at such a
high level with not a lot of time on the
clock so hopefully you guys are enjoying
watching the games maybe even learning
something along the way
watching some of the best chess players
around the world play fast chess so
thanks for watching I'll see you guys in
the next video make sure you also check
out the chess website comm for more
coverage of both the rapid and the Bliss
championship